okay
uh hi stuart hi
shandon um and hello everyone welcome to
our expert
webinar um data lakes and their impact
on digital transformation and analytics
our guest today is chandan dj who is the
senior director of products at cognizant
before we start i'd like to
share controls of the webex
platform uh probably everybody's been to
a webex
seminar by now but when you want to ask
questions we will handle those in the q
and a section at the end of the
presentation so please put those in the
q
a box address them to all panelists
and we will log those and present as
many as we can to chande
uh as a condom as the um
time permits at the end of the session
um
you can also put in chat messages
if you wish they are not visible to
other participants
just to us on the panel be sure to do um
address them to all panelists so that we
do see them
and with that um i'm going to
uh do a poll which is one of the
features we're going to be doing a
couple of times here
um and the first poll is
how much experience do you have and how
are you feeling today
uh that second question is something we
like to ask
since this uh
pandemic situation began make sure
people are feeling okay
working from home and
in isolation so give you about another
30 seconds
to answer the pull
just about another 10 seconds
three two one
and
see the poll result
the audience today is uh heavily
weighted towards people
with uh long years of experience
and i'm sorry the poll question um
didn't quite match what's on
the shared screen but um
but the other thing that's encouraging
is that
most of you are doing well today
and for those who mark the thumbs down
we hope that by the end of the session
you'll have gotten some great
information and be feeling
a little bit clearer so with that
i will introduce chandan
and we will um let him take the
reins after the introduction um he is
the senior director products at
cognizant
um he is an outcome driven digital
technology leader in data
and analytics with over 20 years of
experience in the technology industry
about 17 of that was at
general electric various divisions of ge
in positions of increasing authority um
and he is an expert in this field
and so if you'll bear with us we will
let him continue the sharing
um good morning um and good evening
shonda
show stuart let me just quickly share
the screen and
i can take over the presentation there
you go
let me know if everybody can see the
screen
yeah all right
great stuart do you want to give this
poll or
do you want me to start on this one on
the topic first
i will i will uh start with this poll
for the reason that um
i'd like you to be introduced to
the audience and see how familiar they
are with your topic
let's do this one quickly and again
about
40 seconds
we had a lot of people very interested
in
the subject of data lakes so the
question is how well
are people uh familiar with it
okay
i think pretty much everybody has given
their answers so
okay
let's say most people have are answering
that they've
heard of them got it
all right so let me move forward with
the presentation
and i quickly come to the introduction
of data lakes now
as the poll suggested a broad group of
people
is not very well aware of what data
leaks are or
or how they are in use in
the industry and what exactly is a data
lake data lake is
typically a data repository it hosts
large if i have to call like enormously
huge
large quantity of data amount of data
hosted in an environment
preferably leveraging cloud technology
and using big data technologies which is
like hadoop
hdfs presto spark
scala and so on and so forth the data
lake also hosts
a variety of data which is like it can
be structured data semi-structured data
unstructured data which could be your
file systems and so on and so forth
the applicability of or the applications
usage of a data lake
vary from the analytical tools
to building dashboards reporting
solutions
serving as a data store which is like if
you want to provide data as a service
from a single stream you can serve that
as for that also
it is immensely used in data science ai
and ml
uh services so data lake in summary
huge collection of data you know in a
single
instance or a repository i'll move to
the next one which is
a poll let's move on to a quick growth
so that
it gives me a bit of insights
and what we're going to ask is what your
current job role is and that will
function address the
information to your needs
we recognize that some people may not
work specifically in
data science absolutely maybe they
manage it or
they're an executive or if you're a
student
i think it's going to give me a good
insight to basically talk more on the
areas where people
are in the in the current roles that
they have an inclination towards
moving into a different role
three two one
okay sorry about that no ways
there we go
so we're out we've got 10
executives program program managers
project managers
uh students and others all right
good so this gives me a little insight
about what do i need to
specifically focus more so as i said
right
how do you look at data lake now i'm
getting a couple of questions pinged
across screen
so how do you differentiate data lake
from a traditional database or data
warehouses
or data mods now i think broadly looking
at it
a couple of things which would come into
picture is data processing
you know in a data lake you typically
store data which is unprocessed data now
i will come to later slides which will
explain
why i'm saying this because data lake
primarily is a repository
so any data that you work you're
basically retrieving
it is stored at the very first instance
in an unprocessed way
whereas traditional data mods data
warehouses
databases have process data which is
like you will have your tables you have
schemas
you will have your joins normalized data
structures conditions
primary key foreign keys all associated
with that whereas in a data lake when
the data comes in
it is in their raw format it is exactly
how it is
from where it is coming from the source
system you don't change the data in the
very first instance
it is stored as is into a data lake
now we talked about the variety of data
which is in a data lake
you can have any kind of a data in a
data lake
which can be your file data you can have
engineering drawings you can have
simple text files your twitter feeds
your facebook feeds simple uh
even even transactions which are coming
in from the point of sale registers
any kind of data which can go into a
file system
is kind of put up into a data lake
whereas a data warehouse or a database
will have a structured data you again
will create a schema you will have your
tables you will have joins you will
basically organize the data in a form
which can be basically passed through
query in a data lake your data
granularity
is at the lowest level the transaction
which happens
the data is passed on as is you don't
translate basically that data into a
summary level or aggregated view
which is needed for your reporting keys
in a database house
any transaction for example in a general
ledger or a point of sale
or our twitter feed anything or
everything which is there it just comes
in
as is and is stored in a data lake in
the exact form
as it originated from the source so you
are
having a data granular at the lowest
level
to which you can actually summarize and
when you roll it up
when you talk about latency in a data
data lake
traditionally data lakes are built for
storing data
and combining data into a single entity
therefore data latency typically looked
upon is is a very low one
by data latency what i mean is
the moment the data is created at the
source
the soonest you want it to be in the
lake available
so for example you are at a point of
sale as i mentioned in this example
you are selling an iphone the moment the
transaction is completed it goes into
a database similar at the same time
within a few seconds that same
transaction is replicated into a data
lake
in the totality as how it has gone into
a source
so your customer details your
transaction value
your item that you have purchased all of
that goes
into the daily whereas in a traditional
data warehouse
or our data mod you would
traditionally be getting a data at a set
period of time
maybe every six hours maybe once a day
once all the transactions are completed
if you talk about financial data once
all the
books have closed for the day you would
basically aggregate all of that
transactions you would basically pass on
into your data warehouse
so lake the latency is traditionally
very low you would
you can get almost up to a real-time
data also in the lake
whereas on a database of site or a
traditional database site
uh it's it's at a certain volume level
which is like it may be coming in a
certain period
now the applications of traditional data
warehouse
is traditional reporting you will create
a dashboard you will have certain
metrics which are based on
the data which is in the data warehouse
and you will be rolling up those numbers
to showing it up
whereas the applications usage of for
data lake
expand from as i mentioned it can be
used in in big data analytics
real-time data analytics it can be used
in
a lot of data science applications a
perfect example
that can come across in a very simple
format as if you go to flipkart
or amazon or any other traditional uh
basically websites where you do
your selling the moment you select a
product in amazon
amazon gives you a recommendation as to
what
other customers have traditionally
brought along with that item
now that is an example of basically data
science and then
artificial intelligence built into their
systems which
the moment you're opening up a page
click the link it's
working in background to look at the
data
for that product who all have brought
that product what other products have
they brought it with
and that gives you a recommendation so
in a sense
there is a large variety of applications
that can be used
using a traditional data lake versus a
traditional database
or a data warehouse which contains data
at a summary level or an aggregated
level
i'll move on to the key elements of our
data lake
now typically when you look at a data
warehouse or
a database there is
security which is built into it there is
a transactional
uh which comes into our database or on a
data warehouse you basically
try to match like an aggregated data of
volume data which goes into a data
warehouse
whereas the moment you talk about data
lakes right
it it encompasses a several
large functions which are integral for
making data lake a success
the paramount is security data
governance
because when you're having data at rest
in a single location now you can imagine
let's say
an enterprise is there and they've
created an enterprise data lake
they're having all of their financial
information in there all of supply chain
all of invent related information
basically the entire company's data into
a single repository
imagine if that entity or that object
or that data lake is breached or if
there is a ransomware
attack which happens you have
a big problem on your hand because
you've exposed all of your data
which is addressed to the hackers or the
ransomware people
data quality is is paramount because in
a data lake
whatever data you're getting it is being
used for analytical purposes it is used
for
for reporting it is used for
distribution it is used as a data
repository
so your data quality needs to be very
important data discovery which is like
your what is your catalog what is your
metadata for that
objects that are being stored that's
again very important because
if you want somebody to use your data
lake they need to be able to understand
what data is in there
and how is that data interconnected with
each other you know in a traditional
data
base you only have your basically your
your primary key foreign key
relationship diagrams which are already
there
whereas in a data lake your data is
coming in as is it doesn't have any
relational
objects to it so data discovery and
basically modeling is very important
auditing is another big aspect when you
look at it if you are
getting a data on a very frequent basis
from the source
you want to make sure that the data
that's coming in is absolutely as
same as what is in the source so you'll
have your functional audits you'll have
your
technical audits like if i'm getting 10
rows from the source
i want to ensure at the daily lake i've
got 10 rows even those 10 rows
the sum off of x column is 100 i want to
ensure
that the source and the and the data
lake the number matches
so data auditing is another big aspect
similarly storage data lineage
exploration
is is uh all very different elements
which which make up a data lake and of
course ingestion which is the
one of the most critical aspects because
at the at the very beginning of a data
lake
is ingestion you will identify your
sources of data
which you want to bring into the lake
then you will have a data engineering
and data modeling team
work to create the data ingestion
pipelines
and they will go on basically like
what's the frequency of data that's
getting pulled
and then set up into the data lake how
are you basically setting it up
as an injection layer versus uh if you
recall the replication of the mirror
layer
then how does it go process go beyond
the
replication or the mineral layer which
is like from the source it has come into
the lake
and it's exactly the same for
making the data available for
applications it has different part
paradigms
i'll talk more about it in the next
couple of slides as to how the data is
being moved
made available to different the
consumers
i'll go to the next one now if you look
at traditional data cycle in a life
cycle in a data lake right
the engineers or or basically that
architects would identify
what are the data elements that they
want to basically get into the day
now that could be you have your
financial data you have your supply
chain
you have your logistics data you have
your traditional
uh it can be like hr payroll
any kind of information that is an
organization you want to get into a into
a data lake
now the examples i'm trying to give you
is is trying to create like an
enterprise data lake data links can be
very specific it can be a supply
generated one
it can be a purely logistics it can be
purely a financials
however to make it more efficient more
effective
but the more threaded data that you can
bring into our data lake
the more better results you will get it
and by threading what i mean is
how you can tie back your enterprise
data from end to end
for example you have an organization
which is like a service based industry
right
so you will be having a customer
you're selling a product which can be
your services for example traditional id
company like
cognizant uh you will have your bidding
process you will have you will be
basically
doing proposals for customers so your
customer is an entity sales in another
one
you bid for a project you won the
project the project is created
the next part is the resources aligned
to it so you have your resources data
you have your project data once once a
project is created you have your
work breakdown structures you will have
your immense number of activities that
go into it
so you have your project data you've got
your resources data which is like
the project managers data engineers data
scientists web developers anybody who is
there
their information is there once they're
working on their deliverables you're
making your timesheets where you're
making your work plans
all that information is there once the
project is completed
you pass on the deliverable to a
customer you basically get the revenue
and you recognize the revenue you have
your financial information there so the
end-to-end information if you talk about
enterprise data their house
you have your end-to-end information
from the very beginning of
basically from a bid to a revenue
recognition
that's what an enterprise cycle would
look like so you would understand what
your sources are
the next step would be in the collect
stage basically you understood what your
sources are
how do you want to get it in the
ingestion cycle you would basically
define
how you want to get the data into a data
lake now there are
several tools you can use uh you can
have streaming data coming into it you
can have informatica's
there's another tool a lot of people
might have worked on to it there are
tools like talent which basically pull
data there are tools like
data breaks uh hbr golden gate from
oracle
these are different replication tools
that different organizations use
to get data from different sources and
ingest into
whether it's a database house or data
lake the next step
is blending the data
which is by means is once you've got the
data into our data lake which is your
mirror
you typically want to make the data
available for usage so you basically
kind of
blend the data from different sources to
make it more meaningful
you transform the data now the big
difference between if you talk about
traditional data warehouses
and your traditional aura data lake in
the in the old world if you look at
previously
how the data houses used to work was you
would have your etl jobs where you will
extract the data from the source
you will transform it and you would load
it whereas in a traditional
uh or if you're going to call the
advanced or the modern data lakes
it is elt you extract the data from the
source you load it into the the system
which is your mirror and then you come
to transform the data now the
transformation is basically
a layer which you are making it
available
to basically
making it available to your analytic
tools or your customers for example you
can make it available through a data
store
into a form where people can basically
like say
you have a data store application which
can
combine the data into a single report
and present it to you by
doing certain fact and then dimension
entities and then you publish the data
also to different applications for your
data as a service
or you can do a distribution via
different data pipelines
data as a service again data as a store
and in different mechanisms to to
basically publish two different
applications
which can consume data for example
several data science applications
or the customers use data which is
finally available for distribution
i'll move on to the next step
if you traditionally look at data lakes
the year the etl was
the traditional way you would have your
etl jobs
scheduled to run at certain frequencies
if there's a trigger from source it
would just go
and run at that certain frequency or you
would be running your etls if i had a
call
at let's say an hour or two hours or six
hours
or a daily or a weekly jobs
in a data lake environment your data
processing traditionally happens in
in two ways one is batch processing
and then the second is real-time data
streaming now in a batch processing
let's say
you are having a point of sale
you're waiting for your day to close and
you're basically combining all of the
data
and then getting it back into the data
lake which can be let's say
an early job or it could be a day job
once it's it's all closed
the the the transactions are finalized
in a banking industry you would want to
wait till the day end for example
to make sure all of the data is
completed the bank is able to reconcile
all of the transactions once they close
their data
then you get it processed within the
lake as a batch processing you're
getting it like
for example a three-hour job or a
two-hour job or
once in a day it could be a once a week
also for certainty
transactions it could be once months
once a quarter something like that
uh in other ways you also have stream
processing which is like
the real-time data coming in at a very
low latency
imagine the same example of point of
sale the moment
exactly that the transaction has
happened you're able to send that
transaction into
the data lake also and you're able to
make a historical information processing
also that
even though the data is not finalized
you are still marking it as a data which
is like okay
this is transaction in process you still
are storing in a data lake
so that you understand what the
historical value of a certain
transaction which happens
or for example an example a general
ledger in an organization the moment an
entry is passed
into a general ledger you are moving the
same entry
into the data lake or the moment a
item is received in the data of a house
the the values created in the data
system database
the same value is replicated from the
transactional database
into the data lake and then all of the
transaction happens
in a stream way so that it's basically
the moment the transaction is happening
the data is flowing through the pipeline
and getting into the data lake that's
why it's it's it's
called as stream processing because it's
a continuous stream of data which is
coming through
another example could be your twitter
feeds uh you're getting your facebook
data
coming into a data lake because you want
to process how
what what kind of feeds or values are
coming in
if you're to consider an exam example
for stream processing is like
traditionally when the cricut matches
happening a lot of people are posting
streams
or basically tweets or facebook entries
while they're doing certain activities
the same feeds are basically processed
by several organizations
posted into their data lakes and then
done
a real-time processing to understand
what is the engagement of their
customers or their potential customers
on on their products
i'll move on to the next one which is
smoothly broad talk about
digital transformations for the data
lakes
now when we say digital transformation
it has
a lot of uh way basically definitions
if if you look at it and if you look at
this
specific picture it really talks about
the digital
transformation in the in the real world
because
a lot of organizations believe digital
transformation is basically
converting your applications digital so
you had an excel based
system you basically automated it
through a web-based
application and that is digital
transformation
uh to a certain extent people want to
say yes
i would slightly disagree because or
actually broadly disagree on this one
because digital transformation is
basically how do you look at
your entire business and
transform the business in such a way
that through usage of digitization and
digital tools
you can have more newer offerings
for your customers you can have
newer work streams for your internal
customers for your external customers
how do you make more revenue how do you
make
more profits but not just by digitizing
tools
or applications but how do you change
the way an organization is worked and
that is what i think data lakes
are a very integral part of bringing in
digital transformations
now if you look at the consumers of
a modern data lakes it can range from an
executive
to a marketing operations to product
managers
to your traditional operations analyst
id
functions business users product support
organizations and everyone
now how do you how do you look at these
different consumers
in a transformation way
for example our data architect may want
to look at the data lake
in a way that okay how do i thread the
data in in such a way
in the lake because now the lake has
enterprise data in it
the data architects wants to modernize
the offering for his data
products product manager working with
data architect
decides to say okay i want to make a new
sales dashboard
which gives me real-time insights about
how the sales are happening
what are my key products which are
happening
and how i can make
the visualization for my executives in a
more effective way
now when we talk about data architect
and product managers they're looking at
okay how do i make
the id products such more versatile that
i can make it more
beneficial data architect would start
looking at the different elements that
are in the data lake
and start to thread data as to okay how
do i
start looking at my end-to-end business
process
and connect the dreads now most of you
are working in
in organizations and i'm pretty sure
most of the people would understand and
agree that not
seeing not a single enterprise runs on
one single platform
most of the businesses most of the
companies muscle organizations
have let's say one of their processes
for example let's say
their purchase or procurement process in
a different system
whereas when this when the product is
received
when that when the purchase order was
raised it was run through a different
system
when they actually received a product
against it they would receive it in a
different system
the product
is received the payment is done through
a different system
now if you look at all of these
disparate systems
they are all different different
applications or different tools which
are there
they don't have a clear linkage between
them whenever when our
product manager and data decide no we
want to give an end-to-end view
of my enterprise process that is where
you start threading your data
and saying okay now i want to create my
business process
and whatever data i have and data linux
view i have in the in the data lake
i want to build a model on top of it
which is the mirror layer where i'm
getting the data i want to bring an
analytical layer
where i would basically architect my
data and model my data in such a way
that now i'm able to basically create a
meaningful
end-to-end flow of the data and get
different reporting needs using that
so for example you had data coming into
it through injections
you brought it into a layer
hypothetically let's call it as a mirror
layer
which is like you're getting it from
different systems you've mirrored it
into your data lake now you want to make
that data more
basically usable for your consumers for
your analytic needs
for different people so you're modeling
the data and you're bringing it into a
layer
let's say it's it's your if it's all
let's say
uh presentation layer or maybe let's say
analytical layer
because now your data is in in a
certainly normalized form
where i can still join them and make
them more usable
through that layer the product manager
builds a product which is let's say
i want to make a data store where people
can come
and get the entire sales data
because they want to do their own run
their own analytic in their own
application
so they're able to get that data through
that product similarly through the same
product
the product manager says i want to be
making my visible my financial data
from the lake to the finance community
so that
if they want to substantiate the data
for their executives if they're asking
them for a certain data i'm able to give
them
from the same delay now the lake is
actually working
as a single source of truth for them
for the enterprise now they the lake is
working as a single source of truth
the product managers the data architects
they're all working in conjunction
to make that analytical layer near
meaningful for the analysts
for the business users now a lot of
practicality of a data lake comes in
when the data lake is made available
through the self-service analytics
or self-service data availability
you've got your data lake you've got an
analytical layer you build tools on top
of it
which can be used by your operations
analyst which can be used by let's say
the
marketing operations the analysts the
business users
to build their own analytics to build
their own needs by threading the data
together
now from the mirror you you made an
analytical model
and you brought in the lake the the
difference that the challenge which
comes into this is
traditionally data lakes are meant for
storing data
therefore when you want to build a
system on top of a lake
you may want to call it as enterprise
data warehouse or if you want to use a
data lake
itself for creating an analytical model
you can do it
however traditionally lake has a slow
uh if you recall the processing time
from a pairing data
because a lot of tools that are there in
big data they're meant for
ingesting the data at a very high volume
at a very high speed
whereas if you bring in another system
to pass the data and make it for
analytical needs
that'll be better so if you look at
consumers in a data lake
that is how you start understanding how
a data lake
can actually help you transform the
business in a more
efficient way you have your entire
business data in a single location
in enterprise data you have your experts
which understand those different data
elements if you help
build a data lineage and a data model
and your analytical platform on top of
it
and make it self-service and
self-sustained
then you're making your business more
enabled
to go and look at it okay if the sales
team wants to look at the sales data
in a more real-time way you already are
having a real-time data come into
the lake your analytical need model
needs to be refreshed
at the same frequency and you can make
available
the real-time metric to your executives
your different teams
which are which are on ground in
traditional data analysis you had your
frequency of batches
where the data would get updated the
data would get processed
cleans and then transformed to make it
available for the reporting needs
so you always had if you recall
basically descriptive analytics which is
like okay what has already happened in
past
i'll move on to the next one because
that talks about what i'm talking right
now
if you if you talk about analytics
through your data lake right
now the analytical models that can be
worked through a modern data lakes is
you can have your descriptive data
analytics which is like
uh which is today available through a
lot of traditional data
analytical platforms data warehousing
platforms like okay
you something has happened in past we're
talking about descriptive
it has already happened in past the
transaction is already there we're just
simply bringing into our reporting
platform
and showing that this is what my revenue
was till about months back
this is what my travel spend
was till x date this is how it looked
like
now if you look at the the usage of data
which is coming into a data lake
in a real-time basis you can also build
through a diagnostic
analytics because now we have data
spread across the different domains and
different streams
you're not just having one single domain
which is there so you can try
and try it as to what happened in the
transaction for example you received a
certain product from which
you had the purchase order raised the
payment term was
90 days however the payment wasn't
released
till 120 days now if you had disparate
systems
you probably cannot try edge why this
happen whereas
you know in a data lake in a in a
clearly defined model
in a threaded data you can understand
which are the
purchase orders which we have received
but not paid
and then trying to trash the data
through the receivables and through a
banking system data
you can try as to what happened why did
it happen the transaction failed the
banking transaction failed
because the account number was incorrect
of the customer
and that is all of the triaging which
can happen
when you have a threaded data available
through a data link
in a traditional database or a data
warehouse you cannot accomplish this
because
as i mentioned if you have disparate
systems by
bringing a database into another systems
you are customizing it
which is making it more difficult for
your future upgrades
of your original systems and by that
means you're creating more complexity
creating more operational issues for
your transaction
systems now coming into the next two
parts which is predictive
and prescriptive i think that is where
the data lake
comes into strong play
because when we talk about data lakes we
talked about the
large or the enormous volume of data
that can come in
the second part is the data is real time
coming in
in a broad sense so
in that way the data science the machine
learning the
the artificial intelligence comes into a
play now when you want to do the
predictive or the prescriptive analytics
which is like
in a predictive which you understand
like okay what happened
when it happened you are you're looking
at data and you're trying to build a
model
in a in a data science in a machine
learning model you typically start
building a model
looking at historical data and
trying to play with different parameters
to come to a
situation which is more like your
closest to your
real results so you took a historical
information let's say last 10 years data
it's what data lake and you're applying
your machine learning model onto it
and they're trying to compare as to like
what is my real last one month results
looking like
is is it really what was the result
on those x months which i'm trying to
build a model with
so you have your whole historical data
you built a model
and you compared with your love with
your real-time data in in that model
as to know those period did the model
completely
or 95 match with the real results
and then you start applying that model
into your
fresh data in your upcoming real-time
streams and you start
observing as to what is the efficiency
of that model
so that is helping you because that
large amount of set of data
actually helped build you a much finer
and a much closer model to your your
real world is
the next is basically the prescriptive
analytics which is like okay what
happened with atom
and then the third part is which is
which which a lot of broad
uh if you call analytical school don't
give that capabilities there are some
uh suppliers which do give a lot of
products wherein you can simulate data
as to like if i'm applying my data
science if i'm applying my machine
learning model
in this data and if i'm getting this
result out of which
if i change a certain variable into it
how does it impact my overall model
and how does it impact my result that is
what you're simulating
and that is what you're doing a
prescriptive analytics about as to if
i'm
for example if you're getting real-time
reservations data
into your data link which is your let's
say your travel data your organization
is having
let's say 300 000 people in the in the
company
uh travel spend is there if you
understand
where the people are traveling you can
basically
simulate if you're if you reduce a
certain x number of traveler or
or for a certain business unit if you
say there's a travel freeze
how much of dollar savings is gonna give
you now those are those kind of
prescriptive analytics you can have
through different tools and say okay
if i'm applying these models how much of
benefits it's going to give me or if you
talk about for example you have got your
procurement you have got your payment
terms by applying your data science your
machine learning models
and and giving that okay these are the
biggest suppliers which i have
and if i simulate that if i change my
payment terms from 90 to let's say 150
days
what's my impact gonna be are these
suppliers going to reduce
basically uh selling me the products or
if this customer if i get them more
discounts
will they come to me more so there are
different kind of prescriptive analytics
you can actually start building through
it
now the both the two ends as i mentioned
are
more effective when you have the the
large volume of data available
through a data lake
this is broadly i had in terms of
basically presentations
uh steward arjun i'll book the questions
and answers
control back to you all right
now we're in the questions and answers
and
um we've got a number that came in from
the audience uh
here's an interesting one if erp
from santa if erp is doing the same kind
of job how is it differently
how is it basically different from data
lake
absolutely i think it's a pretty good
question
uh let's let's talk about oracle update
for a second right
and then i'll take an example of uh for
example hr data
now traditionally in an erp you don't
maintain a lot of historical information
for example ohr is an is is oracle hrs
is a data
set when you have
an employee joining in a company you
create a record for him
when the employee moves into a different
role and the roles keep on changing
uh to a certain extent the
different values are maintained to a
maintain
to a certain extent but not the entire
historical information
whereas each of the transaction changes
that happens while it is in
in uh if you were to call in the staging
layers in a different database
you can pass it on to your data lake and
still retain your historical information
so for example a manager hierarchy in an
organization
usually it does not maintain forever in
an organization
as to when you joined your company in
the very first day
what was your hierarchy starting from
you all the way to
your ceo whereas after three years
what is what is the current hierarchy
whereas in
in a data lake what you're doing is you
are basically copying transactions
which are not changed or basically like
in a data lake you're trying to see
if the if the transaction is not changed
the data has not changed i'm not
replicating it
the moment it is it's reflecting the
change you're going to create a copy of
it into a data lake and you can say okay
i want to maintain
a historization of that data now what it
does is
it gives you a complete history of
automated change
a traditional erp stores a transaction
once a gl is finalized
what different sub-ledger entities it
went through it
traditionally would not maintain it so
you lose a certain flow of data
in an erp in a transactional flow system
whereas the moment those changes are
happening where there is a small change
happens
you can still replicate that data back
into your data warehouse or a data lake
and create a historical information of
that and and maintain it forever
so to a certain extent pasteurization is
a big piece
now as i mentioned right erps are doing
a certain amount of work as i said i
haven't
seen a single enterprise in the world
even google runs
multiple erps it's it's world's
finest uh basically company
in terms of your search engines in terms
of products
however when they look at their
enterprise they still run multiple erps
so when you want to thread all of that
information together
you want to make sure that how do you
how do you bring that data together
and how do you make it more worthwhile
for your
customers for your internal users for
your enterprise
and i think that that's that's where
data link differs a lot from erp because
it's not just a transaction system it's
it's basically keeping your
customization data as well it's
threading the data from different drp's
too
we've got dovetails with another
question about um
you know whether a data lake replicates
an
an oltp an online transaction processing
database
as i said the data which will come into
the lake is at the most granular level
the lowest level of entity
so that if you're creating an ecosystem
where you want to give
your ceo a total roll-up number
and the ceo asks a question to his
general manager
how did you arrive with this question
the general manager should be able to go
to his senior manager and say hey
give me a substantiation of how did you
arrive to respond
they should be able to come to a data
mart and say okay give me all the
underlying transactions or the volume
which is there
to be able to prove that so yes it does
replicate oltp
and it will replicate at the lowest
transaction level
is it secure to keep everything uh
all the data in a lake under the same
cloud
are are there
regulatory issues with that or security
issues with that
so if i understand the question you're
talking about is security concern if
there are different
data sets which are there in a data in a
cloud
is that my understanding correct um i
think that's
about correct when uh especially
the questioner asks if data is consumer
oriented
you fall under a number of different
regulations about data security for
consumer information so absolutely
so if we remember like my presentation
talked about the different key elements
of a data lake governance and security
is is
as i said was very paramount because you
may have
the pii data which is like personally
identifiable data
healthcare is a big industry where data
lake is going to play a very critical
role
now if we talk about healthcare as a
development for example
right how do you build up
a great mri machine
build a great mri machine because you
run different machine learning
algorithms on the different
imaging data that you got from the
different machines
across the world and you're applying
your machine learning algorithms in it
to say okay how do i identify if
an anomaly that is shown in an mri which
is like in a healthcare data
is actually a cancerous growth or not
now when you're doing that basically all
your imaging data is actually
the phi which is public health data
which is
and it can be identified or it can be
tagged to a person now us has
severe laws and so does with the
european union and several other
countries
so yes securing the data becomes
paramount in a data lake
especially in a cloud a lot of cloud
native providers
are assuring multiple level of security
and regulatory compliance
and then you can basically work through
your different organizations different
uh auditing organizations like kpmgs or
the big fours
to certify your data lake for example
when i was with ge we work towards
certification
of the financial aid for stock
certification now stocks
compliance is one of the key regulations
and
compliances requirement for financial
use data
for any organization and
you can work through those different
paradigms to get your data like
certified
your cloud providers can help you
basically ensure that there is a right
a level of security implemented in it
now since
data in our data lake is sitting at rest
you may want to implement the
cloud security which is like how do i
encrypt data at rest
how do i make sure that there is right
checks and balances in the data how do i
bring in
rights uh authentication and
authorization levels
so the data is not available to everyone
and everyone
i hope i answered the question yeah that
that sounds like a great answer to that
question um
on a relative related topic of
reliability
uh rushman asks if uh there are
ways to protect against the
vulnerability you mentioned about a data
lake as a single point of failure
right
let me talk about data lake as a single
point of failure yes
however using cloud native technologies
or using cloud technologies i think you
can built
in uh replication capabilities
uh a lot of cloud providers provide more
faster basically turnaround times for
their infrastructure needs
uh having more scalable environments in
your cloud
you can ensure that storage is because
storage is one of the paramount
underlying foundations for any dna
because you're having continuous coming
in data
your storage is the most important and a
lot of us
are aware we had a outage of
google services couple of months back in
in aspect i think it was december
sometimes when the entire services were
not rendered available
now just because of a code change that
went into
their systems which made the storage
not available to the applications so
making sure that you have a scalable
environment you have the right uh
if you want to call the infrastructure
setup
for your scalable and reliable
reliability
when you have multiple nodes for your
data
and your basically replication rules you
can ensure that your
cloud hosted data lake is more reliable
um thank you for that uh we have
just a few more questions uh and there's
a lot of a lot of questions we won't be
able to get to but
uh we have uh i think a few more minutes
for
questions here pioush asks uh does it
make sense to
uh to create a
data lake based on a subject area or to
logically
segment a data lake based on different
functions or subjects
i think it's a it all depends on the
contextual
needs of the data if the business
doesn't wants to basically look at
uh their overall business process but
they want to focus on
a certain specific area for example
finance is as a great area you can have
the complete financials data like
created however to make
meaning of that data also you may still
want to bring in
certain more domains so that the data
can be tied back
to a certain granularity for example if
you want to try back to your data right
your financial data can come from
multiple sources
now you want to make sure that your
payables your receivables
your banking systems data they all tie
back into
into that lake so finance as a function
becomes a data lake
you can look logistics as a data lake
you can look at supply chain
as a data rate however you want to make
sure that the
relevant cross reference data that you
would
want to have is also ingested into a
data lake
so it's not entirely needed to have your
entirely
uh if you would call the enterprise data
lake but you can have a domain specific
data lake
mckillah asks if there's value
in pushing uh data coming from web
analytics tools
like a google analytics into a data lake
um to build up your uh
base of customer and behavioral data
i'm not sure i quite got the questions
to it can you repeat the question one
more
i think what she's asking is
would a data lake be useful in
aggregating um analytics web analytics
like from google analytics
so that you can then analyze uh consumer
and behavioral data
absolutely i mean absolutely if you can
get the lowest
grain of that data into your data lake
as i mentioned
your analytical layer which you can
create on top of your lowest level grain
of data
you can absolutely use that to
run your own models you create your own
models to see what your customer
behavior is
this is an interesting one chris asks uh
how is data blended in the data lake and
how is it contextualized so that
you can make sense out of it and which
tools
are available to um
provide context for different domains
like banking and manufacturing and
e-commerce uh absolutely great question
i think
so data blending
in a sense i would say once you've got
your data up to the mirror layer which
is like you're getting your sources
ingested into your data lake now then
the moment you start thinking about okay
how do i
make it more meaningful outcomes from
this data
i want to grid i want to identify
insights from this data
you want to contextualize it right now
what that what you're trying to do is
you're trying to find for meaningful
data and then the way you do it is
again you find your fact entities and
your dimensions
you're trying to build a data model
on top of your data lake objects and
trying to basically combine the data in
such a way
that you're still not normalizing the
data it's it's still
it's basically in a dnorm format but you
can still use it in different analytical
tools
by combining those different set of
objects and
saying i can create the relationship
between these objects
and i have the lowest transaction into
it now the the tools that you have can
either aggregate the data can present
into a visualize
for example you can talk about tableau
right now
i would take let's say the purchasing
data my banking data
which is like my payments data uh my
bank information
and the receiving information i built
our data model
of all of those different data streams
and put it into my data
analytical layer using tableau or any
other visualization tool
or or let's say oracle business
intelligent suite i can then create a
dashboard
of that data model and either i can
visualize
it or either i can create a tool which
can basically present the data in a raw
format
which is which is made available to the
consumers so the blending happens
through the data architects the data
engineers basically work
to create that architect model wherein
the different disparate data elements
can be combined
to give a more meaningful and an
insightful outcome
through the combination of the data
tools as i mentioned you can have
different visualization tools which can
run on top of it
uh data ico is another one which is
which is there
a lot of people use r and python as
languages
to build their own data model and make
their own outcomes on top of the data
links
so there is not just one tool which is
there but that there's magnitude of
tools
which can give insights and outcomes to
different people
and what skills and courses
should people focus on to become
um
conversant in what they need to know for
data like
using data lakes and incorporating them
into their into their work
um i'm just trying to think through this
so
if i answer the question you're asking
like what skills people should have
uh or how should they think that they
can incorporate the data lake
into their work environment right yeah
uh i think one one piece is thinking
away thinking differently from the
traditional models because a lot of
times
we are so focused and so narrow thinking
on the tools that are already available
or they didn't have houses uh
a lot of organizations have spent time
building data lakes
but not using them and i think that's
that's the biggest mindset change
that start building that air links
with the outcome predefined what you
want to accomplish
as an outcome that should be identified
first
the data lake should come second
understand it if you don't know what you
want to accomplish as a result
it's an outcome as an insight if i want
to give
a more real-time insights and outcomes
to my ceo
i would start thinking about a data lake
which will have more real-time data
streaming
whereas if i want to look at a
traditional way of
thinking about okay i want to give one
quarterback of reporting
a traditional data warehouse still does
the job data label still makes sense
because you can still think about okay
how do i get to the next level
so i think understanding what you want
to accomplish as an outcome
is very critical before you say okay i
want to create a dna
once you've understood what the outcome
you want to drive
i think it becomes much easier for for
anyone to identify
what are the elements that should go
into a data lake or how the railroad
should look like
okay um
i think we're at the at our time um and
we had
a number of other questions that
unfortunately we can't get to
but um i thank you for for um handling
as many as you did
very helpful information for everyone um
and so if you give me a moment here
okay and i want to say again thank you
to sean
for being here uh here is his linkedin
information if you'd like to reach out
to him that way
and you'd like to thank uh
our audience shannon uh absolutely
i really appreciate people for joining
in and listening
i know for a lot of folks in india this
is a pretty late tower
but i appreciate it if you're able to
join in and and able to listen to me
and we will be sending a recording uh
link
out after this event um probably in the
next day or two
so that you'll be able to go back and um
review
um the information that john dunn has
provided
we also want to thank our partner
freshers world
freshers world is a major job portal for
uh india and
we are proud to team with them for a
number of these webinars
um so if you are out there looking
for a job uh they're a great resource
um another great resource is a program
that we've introduced that's simply
learned called skill up
which allows you to access a lot of our
learning content for free
over a thousand hours of the video
courses we do uh
in over 300 skill areas
these are not our certification courses
but these are a great way
to sample the material
and again it is all free so
[Music]
we hope we'll see you at a future
webinar our next one is
next thursday a career webinar
on the change landscape of tech hiring
advice from the cto of hacker earth
about
how to hire tech people in today's
environment
and how to get yourself hired
as a tech professional and that will be
a great session
and please do reach out to us on our
social media channels facebook twitter
and
linkedin we love to continue this
conversation with you
and we look forward again to seeing you
future webinars
um thanks again to trondon and everyone
who's
here today and that concludes our
webinar
thank you stuart good night and have a
good day
to folks thank you
you